as of 2022 we had no debt other than our
house and uh at that time my husband got
a not so good medical diagnosis so that
set us back that year and then
ultimately he decided to make a step
into uh a profession that he wanted to
be in that essentially cut our income
almost in half as a result of those two
things we had to you know tap into those
Safeguard account pretty much depleted
most of them and now we've got some
credit card debt we have stock that is
not in any kind of retirement account do
I sell that stock and pay that little
bit of credit card debt that that we do
have now or should I let that stock sit
and just continue to not accumulate any
more credit card debt but you know just
make payments on that I'm not going to
give you permission to say what you did
was okay what you did was not okay it
was a really bad dumb plan and if you're
going to use every time something comes
along to get yourself back into credit
card debt I can't help you